what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we're going to watch what if season 2
episode 6 season's been good so far been
great way better than season one nothing
is quite reach the heights yet emotionally I
would say of the doctor strange one but dang
animation and overall consistency I'm impressed
with this season I got to say Coy I got to say
I'm impressed you impressed I think uh fa three
and four of Marvel have highs and lows that rival
phases one and two but one and two are more
consistent this is Phase 1 and two quality
yeah man this is great stuff great you know
it's great too if you guys tell us what you
think of episode 6 tell me what you think of the
characters what I'll say maybe I spoiled it koi
but tell me tell us in the comments guys leave
a like don't think anymore don't think anymore
leave a like on this video subscribe and click
this notification Bell you know reaction for
the next episode is up did you figure it out I
think it's the new character took me a second
thanks to pre for help down these highlights
also fly scratch and watch along where you
sink with your own copy of what if available
it's the first time happened super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page thank you to all
been joining us even for this wh if Journey
you guys have been awesome Pome that's one the
best ways to support this channel let's do it
quick asgard's nightmare is the same
in many realities the flames Ragnarok
Odin entrusted the tesak to a village on
Earth after achieving an age of Peace wa
look at that animation dang fire came
for asgar before he had the chance Ser
wow waa this is sick why does this look so epic
damn cool they threw Arcane the destruction of
Asgard would lead to new wonders from a single
Ember of the past the Tesseract survived Ragnarok
okay find a new home in a new world oh the new
world that's cool I wonder if Americans made
this episode M Real Americans white Americans oh
right of the Americans there's only one American
I know of it's more than a linear path said
Benedict cumber bash was in this episode who
was he playing one of The Real Americans
Sherlock that British man one of The Real
Americans man I love corn maze I don't like
corn you don't like corn I don't like corn dude
on the cob by itself with butter and potatoes
on the cheese oh man corn the cob is one of my
favorite things to eat comments you guys like
corn hey what do you think about corn let us
know
I have to read this is America we don't read
here you speak English in my show wat okay
wat oh like water okay kahori I think the new
character right they're all technically new
characters that's true the one to be an ech
know you're sorry don't mean to be that guy
W I wonder what specific language you're
speaking Tess
power what's the sky world to
them uh that's not the
American where no no it's not
frankly so far I love the choice to do
this because this feels very refreshing
and so different than the pace and
where it is in the season just after
halfway don't trust the Ducks they bring bad
luck our people they look
happy hey oh Spaniards they can't kador first
right so is this episode what if settlers
didn't wipe out most of a race of people and
take over their land not sure Americans
would make that story what if we didn't
horribly ruin a na that allowed us
to make this story you're watching
today oh decoy Lake decoy hey hey oh kill
them before they find out go in the lake yo
I think you're right I think whatever's in
this Lake the powers and stuff is going to
link to Ekko I think you're I think
you're absolutely right about that
golly damn some
blood wow the structures are
gorgeous whoa Destiny awaits
you it's like there's no water around her
cuz we don't know when the testra first came to
Earth so fair it could still be useful in in the
cannon whoa they like embrace
it so the sky world is like an actual plane after
the fall of Asgard fascinating the tessera took
on a second life among cord's ancestors remember
all the ancestor stuff in the phase four has been
very thorough gifting its power to the lake
Warriors adventurers and other Noble tribes
people disappeared like constellations greed
and grief ignited a terrible battle amongst
the surrounding Nations Peace was made and
the lakes's blood soaked Shores were deemed
cursed deterring all from returning to it
interesting keeping it safe all but one what
cool so much about Elements of
Life
for you can't I don't know if it's oneway Street
that's where Ben a cumber batch comes in handy ah
portals May should have Ben to come batch in the
title it does kind of give us a place to wait for
okay got you that makes
sense he is Sinister I really appreciate that
they put most of this in a different language
all of it so far except the opening
right yeah and two different languages
is the implication that the Watchers connected to
these people that'd be interesting seemed like the
eyes they
gone on Deet Mary Sue she learned fast in her
recite 30 minute episodes too much power too fast
F can't you build something to get to the portal
or pull her with the telek right
and then oh there you go maybe
not nail it nail it
ouch absolutely beautiful I love
the use of variety of colors and the
painting style is really cool they really
threw down for a different style for this
one but it doesn't feel alien to the
style it it it Blends nice yeah give call
wow Buffalo leaves Trail look at that
it's like Speeders cool what a fast
fting new aspect of the world to incorporate into
Marvel join alongside
them it's a great sense of
like landscape and scale
man
it feels like scopic there's
depth to all this good point yeah
wow whoa she Dark Knight flipped that
animal oh
cool pick up those five big ones
G dig ones you know what they
I feel like no one ever runs into a
conflict here seems chill it's a nice
place she's forgotten all about the
people suffering back home I got these
shiny Jewels why does she have such a
special power cuz she's the new Marvel
character that looks weirdly
delicious
I would love to reveal that bened batch is playing
him we been waiting this whole
time he's playing a Spanish voice
character this episode's doing an a very
interesting job of capturing the horrors
and wonders of this exploration also
like our blind belief in things like
you don't have [__] about that
water like I mean I still jump into
it the depth of of the animation still so
impressive I feel like they threw down their
best work on this one for animation I'm talking
probably because like they're introducing a whole
new element in new characters sure they
had to make it really count also there's
a level of delicacy and sensitivity to the
world so it adds to that yeah no he's like
Thomas and Pocahontas yeah get down oh NE she
is the one she is the one she's got all the
powers don't use these powers for
evil there's no talking with these people
that's weird what a weird
concept oh it's trying to help her get
home bring the portal to you you
get used this power for good plot-wise I do think
it it's really cool it's beautiful and I love a
lot of what they're doing but damn there's she is
moving along the super power speed really fast oh
yeah that she just learned that she had them
one thing about it that's P that portal down
yeah we can't take these guys
yeah why would they want to
leave I feel like Ekko is going to be connected
to her bloodline yeah I definitely think this
connects I don't feel like her character will
be in live action but I think her character will
connect to her blood like years Generations ago
ancestors yeah or the legend of kahori influences
her take revenge it's what Heroes
do I mean save people yeah yeah
yeah but also murdered violence and
blue give us our release this is
Unchained oo that's cool again the horrors and
wonders they're really good at
capturing it the unknown I got
dead whoa she like
saon damn that's so cool from her over
the POV that's badass oh my God even
like the elements the Great Sound is on
in this episode too I love everything's
going on in the background yeah
the depth is the deepest I've
seen that's messed up uh you
guys are you're literally Canon
guys wow this music is
beautiful she slowed it The Melancholy is very
much underscored I will say even though she got
her powers quick and she's like still invested I'm
still so emotionally invested in her that's the IR
very impressive yeah normally that gets me away
from being invested but I'm very invested in a
character wa that's a cool image lead the
Rebellion oh my God cool stop his faing I
didn't know if they'd come that's cool wow it
is like a catharsis wh if scenario got rid of
the settlers the bearing the what if then we
wouldn't have the show that's true any this
yeah ooh smash is facing had a bunch
of spit come out of my mouth decimate
him stay in the video damn look at
now you guys are buried in there I
I I really hope they got like actual
Native American people to consult on
this unit all the skill they developed from
buffalo hunting kord's Victory wasn't because she
merely chose the right path because she remained
true to her course unwavering in the face of both
Devastation and miracles alike hell yeah is often
what burns brightest what elevates an individual
to something more this feels more like a Disney
Animation than is the animation lately yes good
point
who's this guy Benedict
Cumberbatch the people whose
Nation you're trying to take
just invaded yours and they'd be so
superstitious those people be like
terrified she learned
Spanish trying to say that they should work
together love that
symbolism the Miracles of the sky world to bring
peace to the their neighbors Bravo there he is
World Peace in record time sure that'll last
but I digress and I've been looking for you for
a long time that's how she gets recruited not
by a good Benedict don't we only use Benedict
in the thumbnail we need to get a white man in
there the Conqueror get the views uh is he not
Supreme the whitean oh jeez wow holy balls yeah we
watched a lot of what if today but what's really
made it easy is the clothes were weing he's not
wrong we're comfortable I I I find my transitions
more amusing than anyone else as the comfort of
the day is resting completely on these oh that's
incredible Mohawk Nation who collaborated like
we we had hoped oh yeah seriously what what I
would say is collaborating with other artists
to help bring animated shirts to life is the
deepest collaboration you could hope for at
reation sha.com is a great way to look good
and support the Chanel and be comfortable you
know what I'm saying five hours Greg six hour
we're we're deep in where we at it doesn't matter
at this point doesn't matter what is time in the
Multiverse in the TVA we're all trapped in it COI
yeah I think you should go first ah as the whiter
of us all right here we are uh I liked the World
building I did are you trying to steal the show
yep I'm going to conquer it are you trying to
take away I'm going to first are you trying to
claim ownership over what was tray here now I am
I did this I this is my victory this show this
episode uh I really enjoyed the World building uh
and both visually and that it was like so full of
depth that you could see the world and I I really
enjoyed the feeling of exploration because of
the depth right like it not only had a story that
was exploratory and you mentioned a few times the
fear and the intensity and the adventure sense
but also by using the animation to paint more
detail in the depth it also felt like you were
exploring not only narratively but visually and
I thought that was really interesting because it's
a story about exploration and I found myself not
only being curious about the characters narrative
exploration but visually exploring the background
I sure that was conscious but I I don't know
if I've ever noticed it so pointedly where I
was distracted by the foreground and background
being disperate and then I found myself noticing
it and then thinking oh that's cool because it
ties into What exploration would feel like and
that that making the whole feeling more immersive
so I dug that um character I did obviously have
the 30 minute problem of having to develop uh the
who the character was have the origin story get
powers get the power strong enough to take on
the villain have a conclusion that's not fair
to any character it did obviously have to move
along fairly quickly but I did really enjoy that
the powers felt so magical they felt so part of
the Earth but like really there was a a spirit
to it that I really dug so even though the power
acquisition and use was far too fast I did really
enjoy the the tangibility of that that Wonder so
what I heard from that was looking at all that
open land in the depth mhm the you wanted to take
no for me I want to go all back back there and up
here foreground mine background go as soon as
possible because it looks available they're
cluttering it frankly they could move along
there this is a really interesting story to me
because uh you know like I'm I'm well educated
on the subject cuz I saw killers of the flower
man and and Pocahontas which Disney film to my
understanding kills of the flower Moon not very
accurate Pocahontas documentary extremely accurate
yeah surprised How brave they were truly can you
paint with all the colors of the wind no and the
love story between those two my God the passion I
can't believe they took they absolutely the mutual
passion the the not one directional the theual
passion oh jeez dark joke it's a dark joke of
course we pled in this mood on this episode um
it's it's an interesting story to tell because
uh like it's a very rightfully so it's still a
very sensitive subject as it should be despite
whatever awkward jokes Co are making it's a
very serious subject and then they tell this
um almost cathartic like story of world PE I
was I was joking about it like what if if they
didn't conquer and like we're going to do that
story that's the story they're they made what if
Pocahontas got hurt it's like Tarantino telling
is like Jano story or like what if the glorious
bastards killed Hitler they did it on oh they're
doing this they're actually doing the tail
of what if they were imbued with something
that allowed them to keep to to rival but what was
neat was they didn't use it through like you know
typical Western tradition of giving some bows and
arrows you know right right yeah let's appropriate
their culture just enough to make it about how we
perceive them they they interpreted the Tesseract
capabilities as something one with Mother Earth
yeah that they cuz that they are like spiritually
in tune with and are able to absorb because
it's like looks like what the Conquistadors
that they don't get any absorption no cuz they're
not connected to the world yeah even when they go
into the other realm they uh the I forget what
the did they say who the people are is are is
it I don't know like the people who consulted
um I think the Mohawk nation is is who they
were representing in animation in real life cuz
I know in okay EO it's kamanche Nation right so
this is a different Nation um not all Native
American people are the same there's not one
First Nation what under God indivisible um with
liberty and justice for all the people that were
conquered uh Kenny I have no idea I pronounce like
Kenan Kenyan I yeah I don't know how to pronounce
that anyway uh what were we talking about before
that Co I'm so sorry uh we were talking about buy
a shirt guys by buying shirts which supports
our nation supports us the reject Nation to
to talk to keep doing videos of this quality of
caliber it is so we literally we if we known this
was the episode we would not have been committed
to the slap Happy we've been filming for 5 hours
version of this episode we should probably take be
actually sincere and like focused up oh I we're so
sorry um but I I I you were talking about how the
absorption of the Tesseract was really beautifully
tied the spirit yeah yeah so I love I love the
uh what they're embodied with with the power
set to be able to take back what is theirs right
rightfully so and then for them and they shared
the Earth and they said that your health is our
health I thought that was beautiful and I me as
much as I made my Tarantino comparisons Tarantino
would have been like we're killing everyone oh
we're going to Spain and we're murdering yeah it
would have been just a violent bloodfest and then
they wanted peace their health is your health
which ties into the Earth that such a beautiful
sentiment yeah yeah there was a lot of beauty here
and I do think on the animation level this is when
they decided we have to do our it's already been
great and far exceeding um season 1 and what they
did here was superb like this felt we're often
hearing about Disney Animation not feeling that
grand or feeling like Disney Animation this F this
felt like Disney animation like this is a real
short film we're watching do you know how we uh
we've talked about how Age of Ultron was the first
thing Disney Acquired and then they you know how
we talked about the mic thing and that it's not
a toothpick remember it's literally in everyone's
ear when you're playing with it do you remember in
Age of Ultron when Pocahontas the not Pocahontas
the Pinocchio song um Age of Ultron uses it which
fits for the narrative story but everybody was
like oh the disi Aon remember that era and ever
since there's been the occasional Disney and
every so often like oo that do feel Disney I
say this in Reverse this is a compliment this was
really cool because it felt like a Disney story
in Marvel in a positive way not that they Marvel
muddled Disney or that Disney muddled Marvel this
felt like a beautiful Union of Disney Animation
that from our childhood and a Disney story but
with Marvel allowing it to be a little bit more
it's had an edge to it because of how it ended and
it felt like you know a superhero story this felt
like what Disney and Marvel would would happen in
organically and that was really cool some people
will immediately jump on the fact because it's
a female character too of like like we we were
criticizing the whole thing of her learning really
fast right but still managing to be emotionally
invested in the character you know let's not
forget drct strange shows up at the end of this
episode he learned pretty freaking fast too yeah
so I mean she learned a little faster but yeah 20
minutes what what are you GNA do it's 20 minutes
um and I I I think what's really neat about it
is I think you sent in the trailer reaction of
of how like Harley Quinn was invented for Batman
the Animated Series and now it's character in the
comics and I feel like we could do the same thing
with her and they're we're often hearing about oh
you know why are you gender swapping or or race
swapping a character just create a new one well
now they've done it yeah here you go now they've
created the character and into a multiversal
cannon that could tie into the main cannon in
some way I do think this power set in some way
l AG wise can tie cuz it can still tie into Echo
and something I think it will whether it's like
a legend whether it's uh you know another tribe
Legend whether it is directly to her I'm really
curious th% U but I do I like your your parallel
that with Harley Quinn because that's a character
I love especially because her invention I totally
um culturally appropriated your parallel I you
took myally cited that you said it interaction and
then you went I like that parallel that you said
hey that thing that I said like your parallel I
like my past Theory no but like Harley Quinn it's
a good point you just made where did that come
from man July Koy was smart uh no but like uh
Harley Quinn I love because it's a character about
escaping um un unlikely odds and it could have
been a gender swapped Joker but they they made
her a character that was kind of in a horrible
situation because of Joker and she escapes that
I've always love the idea of a character being
stronger than its invention itself like what a
what a powerful thing that a character exceeded
its medium what a powerful thing that a character
is able to and in this case it beautifully mirrors
the character itself like Harley Quinn escaped
the shackles of being just a TV sidekick to
the Joker and she escaped narratively by being
stronger than the Joker and able to leave that
that oppression I would love if a story about a a
First Nation character that is telling the story
of what if they weren't all destroyed gets to be
a true First Nation hero because so many of those
people didn't get the chance to exist in modern
day uh there are still obviously uh First Nation
people and Indigenous folk um to this day but we
the the scale is so astronomically small because
of the atrocities this is saying what if didn't
happen so I'd love if if similarly there was an
opportunity for a presence that isn't around
in day-to-day life to the scale it should be
by having a character that gets to represent a
nation of people that doesn't have a voice HT as
much yeah I thought this was a really well done
episode overall guys uh I've been really loving
what I thought this would feel like a chore we've
texted a lot this week about like all right I like
should we just skip it yeah especially like the
the holidays and and maybe this won't get views
or whatever but but I've been enjoying it in
terms of our experience we've had fun I've had
fun doing this with you we still got a few more
to go and I've had fun not just because we're
filming together but because it's genuinely been
surprisingly it's not just better it is a caliber
what is it a metaphor for another French I swear
it's like wow they just it was okay and now it's
like a whole new caliber of this is not just
better it is it has reached a whole new terrain
of great I know other franchises have done that
yeah but all the ones I think are genre changes
alien is good aliens is different but like they're
both good I can't think of something that like
oh God why can't we've been for hours there's so
many that have done it and I just can't think of
so many sequels that are better than the original
just like wow no you should just watch this one
I can't I can't think of any right very tired oh
parks and re season 2 that's a fair yeah because
Parks Rec Season one is good but Parks Rec Season
2 gets great all right guys yeah there you go this
is the Parkson Rec Parks Rec Marvel you're welcome
starlord it is the parks and rec bring it all back
to Chris PR Parks and Rec surely is the parks
direct season 2 of Marvel television guys we
need a I gotta record re moon it's a it's a b you
you scheduled a bold day then I got to edit just
a bad normally I my forever made it this far
normally it's like two hours of shooting and
then a bunch of computer work for like 10 been
here over five hours and now it's today it's
the inverse it's like a few hours of editing and
just a whole bunch of filming cuz I want to have
Christmas Day Christmas deck have a Christmas
deck you a good better thing to power through
than stuff like this still grateful have you all
here thanks for joining me that's Say by bye now
bye